welcome everybody to another exciting titillating
into the impossible adventure with one of my
longest term friends I can't call him an old
friend he's barely older than me but he has been a
mentor an inspiration and really set the tone for
the field for many many decades now unbelievably
and uh and that is Professor Mark kamienkowski
who is the third guest who is a professor at Johns
Hopkins University after Adam Reese and recently
Sean Carroll and so and maybe well I don't know
you don't consider Mario olivios to still be there
right he's no longer Affiliated in any way is he
I think he's retired from Space Telescope
yeah yeah so it is Mark haminkowski renowned
cosmologist and theorist and really uh the reason
that I'm probably having this podcast if it wasn't
for him we'll get into that in just a minute Mark
how are you doing today and Good Old Baltimore
it's like uh in the 60s here which for us is
a very big deal yeah yeah it's a nice day good day
for a crab cake luncheon out there I I yeah I'm
suffering through 57 degrees here in San Diego
so a rare day when it's warmer in February out
there than it is here uh so today we're going
to talk uh this episode is tentatively titled
Mark I should have told you beforehand does
cosmology need a therapist and it's because
of all these tensions anxieties crises that
cosmology is allegedly suffering from but
before we go into that one uh that uh which will
be the substance of this conversation I wanted to
uh just bring my readers on an adventure as you
may know if you've listened to the podcast before
seen it before I always start off with authors
and I ask them to judge books by their covers
which is you're never supposed to do that
but what else do you have to go on so we're
going to judge this book uh Mark it's called
losing the Nobel Prize you may have heard of it
uh there are many chapters dedicated to mark
kaminkowski but um but I talk about the time
in 1999 before I met you I knew of you but you
were still at Columbia at the time and I was
destined to meet you when you became a professor
at Caltech and follow your career ever since and
in this particular vignette I'm describing how uh
I spoke to you the day before the famous bicep 2
press conference which occurred uh now it's going
to be what uh nine years ago yeah nine years ago
on uh on St Patrick's Day 2014 where Mark was at
the famous press conference and I was not and I
remember you telling me on the phone that there'll
be other press conferences for you Brian uh and
uh but but actually the time I want to go back
to in the book is when I first encountered you
and really the reason that you were there at
that press conference perhaps is because you
really inspired the bicep series of experiments
um indirectly or directly via a paper you wrote
with a good friend of mine as well as collaborator
Andrew Jaffe and lemon Wang was he a grad student
was a postdoc it was great yeah I mean
he was a spectacular scientist he was
one of the adventures of fantastic when he's
a grad student the University of Pennsylvania
he came he got him in Colombia because he had
family reasons to want to be in New York City
um and we wrote that paper we wrote several others
that the people still read and pay attention to
um he was great but then he um the reasons
that he had this to come to New York state
for a postdoc were also reasons he ate
one at the remain in New York City no and
um it's not easy to like navigate an academic
career and you're limit yourself to one small
tiny little town yeah New York has its charms uh
a lot of people have uh have relocated from New
York City but uh uh but but we're not gonna get
into those details now I want to discuss the paper
that you guys wrote together which was called
the polarization pursuers guide or PPG and for
me it became an another version of an inspiring
manuscript like the version of Jay pasakov the
late great I'm fortunately Jay passed away uh
just a couple of months ago uh he wrote The
Field Guide to the stars and planets with Donald
Menzel at Harvard so he's one of his advisors and
that book inspired me when I was 12 years old to
get my first refracting telescope and uh become a
an astronomer of some Renown trying to follow in
Galileo's footsteps by the way today's Galileo's
birthday February 15th we're recording this happy
birthday 486 years old he looks he looks great
he looks great uh but anyway this paper that you
wrote inspired me and the reason it was is because
it was the first time I or anybody else really
heard an inkling that one could measure the B mode
polarization of the CMB and do it experimentally
and the extrapolation which I drew from the paper
was that you presented a series of graphs
and we'll show those in the b-roll here
um but you presented a series of diagrams and
those diagrams presented how well could a given
sized aperture telescope constrain the amount
of inflationary gravitational wave energy or
the amplitude of primordial gravitationalize and
I saw that it was almost independent of aperture
size and that really lit my fire because uh as
as many people may or may not know a telescope's
cost scales basically with the cube of its
diameter some high power of the aperture so
you were basically telling me at that time and
anyone else who would listen that a 10 meter
diameter telescope was not necessary to detect the
primordial gravitational wave background and that
really inspired me and I I stopped working on the
projects I was working on for Sarah Church and she
promptly fired me which then brought me down to
work with uh your friend and my mentor Andrew so
you were Stanford before yeah I was at Stanford
in 99 miserable hated working on living in Palo
Alto on a postdoc salary of thirty two thousand
dollars during the.com boom when you know uh
Google was getting founded down the street I had
no money no prospects uh really wasn't interested
in the science that you know Sarah had you know
she had she did nothing wrong but but I was so
distracted by some of the ideas that I'd read
about in your paper and others and really became
infatuated that I wanted to do this and I want to
study the B mode polarization or the micro backup
and that later became the uh impetus for the bicep
experiment so bicep we can have actually here is a
replica of the bicep lens that we use the primary
aperture lens for one of the bicep prototypes that
we built back at Caltech where I was a postdoc
and you were a professor and this telescope is
very cheap I cut I mean we got started with a one
million dollar uh you know Grant from president
David Baltimore I think that was one of the Nimble
features of the uh of a small institution like
Caltech in in addition to teaching people how to
weld and do Technical College things caltech's
very Nimble I don't know if UCSD or Johns Hopkins
like that but at any rate um that paper inspired
me to go on this adventure and since then we've
had four generations of bicep and now we've uh
we're in the third generation of of uh the Simon's
array and polar bear and it's very similar it's
on a refracting telescope but your University
co-member colleagues class and and then of course
Simon's Observatory which I lead with my friends
at Berkeley and Princeton and UPenn and Chicago
so anyway Mark I want to thank you for that but
bring us back to that to that time did you realize
the implications when you guys were working on
this paper were you mainly trying to motivate
why it would be interesting or how one could study
it or did you really want to parse the differences
between a large expensive telescope and a
small you know relatively inexpensive telescope
um I think that what happened
there if I remember is that um
there was sort of this mindset at the time
um you know the you know the big CMB experiments
at that time the most successful one was Kobe
and you know we all knew Kobe we understood how it
worked we looked kind of understood the analysis
were and um you know I was a grad sorry a postdoc
in the mid 90s early 90s and I started getting
interested in the CMB and I saw you know and
starting to work on the CMV I went through a whole
bunch of calculations I gave myself exercises I
could sort of understand what was going on and
um you know Kobe worked by scanning the
entire sky and we sort of had this mindset
that a cosmic microwave background experiment
to be successful had to scan the entire Sky
um and it turns out that Kobe was the best
um strategy that full Sky strategy was the
best strategy for the signal that they were trying
to detect which was the temperature fluctuations
um and if you look at the you know the power
Spectrum for a CNB temperature fluctuations it
Peaks at large angular scales and the fluctuations
get become much smaller amplitude at small angular
scales and so I you know I wasn't around when
they designed Kobe but in retrospect that was
the best way to actually discover what they
wanted and ultimately discovered um but then
you know in the mid 90s I and Arthur and Albert
Stevens and urush and Matthias and other people
were writing papers about the polarization and
one of the things that was striking about the
polarization is that the fluctuations in the
polarization um are larger on small angular
scales than on large angular scales and so we did
the straightforward calculation of the paper that
you're thinking about which was essentially just a
generalization of like the kinds of exercises that
I and other people had given ourselves you know
to learn about how these measurements are done but
um it was pretty clear just looking at the
polarization power spectrum that since it
Peaks at smaller angular scales you don't need
the full sky and you don't need all it also not
a piece on smaller angles get sort of Peaks at
middling angular scales they also didn't need you
know the extremely high angular resolution that we
were pushing for in our efforts to like you know
uh advocate for experiments like wmap to measure
of plasma to measure on cosmological parameters
so it's a pretty straightforward exercise the
conclusions in that paper probably could have been
reached just by looking at the polarization power
Spectrum without actually any detailed calculation
um but I think putting in the intent of putting
in that paper was to like draw attention to this
um because you know I'm not an observer
I was even less of an observer back then
but I did know enough to know that
you don't need a big telescope to do
um you don't need particularly good into a
resolution and I also know enough that it's
easier to appoint a telescope or small
part of the sky than the entire Scott
I think we took the title of that paper from
a book that had been written called the Higgs
Hunters Guide yes um for um article
theorists onion Haver Sally Dawson
and I'm gonna get in trouble okay yeah I think it
was Gordy yeah yeah I have the best one of those
books that you buy and you never read uh but
because I I thought I thought it was slightly
more practical to build something to look for
gravitational waves you know on a table top
size then look for the Higgs uh but we'll get to
the Higgs and we'll get to other other challenges
and crises and cosmology but just a quick pause
to ask you for a small favor while my thumb is
occupied with old Albert on it yours is presumably
freed up to leave a thumbs up on this video really
helps me a lot with it good old-fashioned YouTube
algorithm thanks a lot now back to the video but
but I guess the question I had is you know back
then you were also responsible for the formalism
which I think is both more you know poetic uh
I fight with Matthias about this all the time
uh you know EB versus grad curl I think it's more
evocative more descriptive to use the description
you and Arthur and uh Stevens came up with but
but the kind of milieu if I remember from middle
of my graduate school in the mid 90s late 90s
that was also concomitant with looking for you
know Cosmic sheer or looking for Galaxy sheer
and correlations which I want to ask you about
that because I don't really hear so much about
I mean we hear about gravitational lensing and
even in the CMB but these were in like kind of
optical surveys if I recall correctly where you
first really and maybe it was Stebbins you know
who had with Nick Kaiser if I recall correctly
and others that really started to look into
these you know Brad curl type phenomena but
in contradistinction to the CMB I almost never
hear about those types of measurements what
what happened there did we just solve that
field or did it get superseded in some way
you mean um replenishing of galaxies yeah just
Optical you know surveys of weak lensing and in
the formalism of grad curl you know and presenting
it people do that it's huge it's um it's one of
the cornerstones of you know the DS Dark Energy
survey analyzes cosmological analyzes that
Galaxy clustering they've got bearing acoustic
oscillations but they also have weak cleansing so
that's huge um formalism or are they like how what
is the kind of metric rubric that they're using
because I remember back oh geez you know ground
and curl so they're looking for they're using
weak lensing to measure the mass distribution
and for them it's just the grad or the e-mode
um they don't really need the curl there's
no reason they don't really need the curl for
anything um or the P mode um you can use it um you
can measure it with a experiment I think they do
um is a null test all right so very good
null test because it's the you know the
whole analysis pipeline that you that
you developed uh to measure the emote
um you can just change essentially one
line of the code just rotate everything
by 45 degrees and then do the same measurement
that gives you the B mode or the curl component
and um you're doing everything right that should
be zero right so it's a it's an unfortunately
yeah so they do they use it but they don't use the
language of E versus B because it's not really uh
they just have cleansing now that's tracing
matter distribution I mean it what what to
what does that owe itself to is it is it too dark
matter at low z because obviously you know Plank
and other CNB act and spt and so forth and polar
bear can measure you know gravitational lensing at
high red shift and Trace things along the line
of sight and there's a redshift kernel that is
involved but what is the if you had a rank kind of
the DS and other surveys you know kind of motive
force or motivation for them I mean what to what
extent does weak lensing you know hold a candle
no pun intended to things like Baron acoustic
oscillations and other other phenomenals it's
right up there I mean it's not better or worse
it's different um if you look uh there's been
a lot of attention to this Sigma 8 tension in
recent years and you can look um you know they're
you can look at the papers or you can look at
the summary plots that people show in conferences
there's a whole bunch of different data points
measurements of this amplitude of clustering
and the current uniforms or recent universe
and some of those come from weak lensing some
of them come from Galaxy clustering um and
they're all falling more or less in this a
little bit low compared to what you expect from
the CMB and they all have comparable error bars
so yeah weak lensing of galaxies is I think right
in there it's one of the the Cornerstone you know
physical cosmology measurements that people
are doing that so we've got a lot of guests
on recently talking about alternatives to things
like inflation to things like lorentz invariance
as a as a you know conserved symmetry we'll
get to those but the one I want to turn to
First in our list of crises which goes along
you know hand in glove perhaps with uh you
know weak lensing that we just discussed uh
are alternatives to particulate dark matter
um and those are things like Monde uh so I've
had on Stacy McGaw from my alma mater undergrad
alma mater Case Western and also from Mordecai
Milgram uh from uh from from Israel so I had both
of them on discuss their their and it seems
to me and maybe I'm wrong but there's almost
um it seems to be like a Renaissance now with with
people looking at Mond but of course you know you
you're not bound by any you know uh desire to play
politics it'll tell me what you really think how
seriously should I take Mom I'm just a simple
humble experimental cosmologist Mark so break
it down for me and my audience what do you as
a National Academy you know the one of the most
respected cosmologists alive uh what do you think
of of mod on a practical basis has it cleared any
hurdles that would cause you to say put your money
or the nsf's money where their Mounds are and put
a grad student or a postdoc sick them on a problem
um honestly I don't like bonds I don't some
whether I like it or not I don't pay attention to
it and I'm gonna say something that I often say
and you know in small groups don't worry there's
only three thousand people subscribed don't worry
I just I don't think it's good science um so Stacy
does these analyzes that I think are interesting
um you know Stacy's got a whole bunch of galaxies
for which it has well measured rotation curves
and then he fits you know semi-analytic curves to
those data and I think that um that's interesting
and I think um a it's a it's a useful piece
of information or a set of a data set that um
theories for Galaxy formation and Galaxy structure
should in principle be able to account for
um I don't however like the idea
of Mond as an alternative to
dark matter and the reason is it's
just not the theoretical business
um we've been developing you know our modern model
for physics um for a long long time started you
know quantitative descriptions of nature started
with Isaac Newton they were developed further by
assorted mathematicians and physicists in several
centuries um you know Einstein then took things
further in terms of a relativistic description
and it didn't so you know it didn't rule out
or replace Newtonian gravity but expanded the
realm of applicability and clarified the realm
of applicability and then you know the big mom was
we found quantum mechanics we found that there's
you know certain mathematical framework that
describes the behavior fundamental particles
um now the mathematics that underlies all these
things is complicated but it's always motivated
by the most simple physical principles and the
most simple ideas that we have in nature the most
Elementary things that you can think of are firmly
encoded in those mathematical theories so you know
one thing that we start with when we develop
a mathematical model for physics you know the
workings of the universe is we say it should be
Universal we shouldn't have one theory that works
on Earth another one that works on Mars one that
works on Tuesday and one that works on Thursdays
um we should have one physical Theory that
explains phenomena everywhere and at all times
and so that notion of the invariance of the
laws of physics under time translation and
spatial translations gives rise to
conservational momentum and energy
we can then generalize those to the relativistic
context that Einstein brought us to and again that
gives us additional symmetries of the laws of
physics further constraints on the mathematical
structure and in quantum mechanics we have
internal we have rotational symmetry spatial
translation symmetries you know all these very
simple common sense very basic Common Sense the
laws of physics shouldn't depend on whether I
look in that direction or that direction that
gives us conservation of angular momentum and Mom
just doesn't have these symmetries built into it
um the mathematical structure is sort of will try
what works here and over here we'll try something
else and um it's just uh I don't like it so it's
it's it's not only philosophic it's not only sort
of uh you know based on on philosophy but you know
as they say the the Gustavus sesputandam you know
you can't really account for Taste but just to
push back with my trademark love and respect
for you um aren't the most interesting things in
physics the result of broken symmetries not not
perfectly I mean if symmetry was absolute that's
a very good point but um the broken symmetries
that we have in nature um are manifestations
of situations the the the underlying symmetry
is still built into the mathematics so for
example the election week standard model
um the theory has built into it certain internal
symmetries we refer to as Su 3 cross se2 across
if you want the su2 cross U1 symmetry the
electric standard model is spontaneously broken
um so when we discuss the low energy you
know observational um phenomenological
consequences of the theory they are in this broken
symmetry phase but the underlying symmetry still
um is apparent in the mathematical structure
I mean another example is when we look at
um you know condensed matter physics so and
you know according to what I said the laws of
physics should be invariant under translation
but when you look at a crystal you know and
that's a matter of physics you've got a regular
periodic array of atoms and so you no longer have
um you know spatial translation symmetry um
unless it's by that certain lattice separation
um but still the the underlying physical theory
is still invariant under spatial translations
but subject to the you know but describe the
particular physical configurations you're
looking at so even when we have spontaneously
broken symmetries um in nature of the underlying
symmetry is still built into the it's still
respected I see so what about I was speaking
on a podcast with my colleague Dan Green uh who uh
is you know renowned and astroparticle physics and
um kind of making a slow conversion from you know
String Theory as a you know daily practice or you
know the daily homage to string theory and I'm
really getting into observational signatures for
for experiments like the Simon's Observatory but
um you know I asked him yesterday I'll ask you
later you know what are some of the most you
know foundational things that you've learned
or facts about the universe that you'd want to
brag about and put on a monument a time capsule
to last a billion years we'll get to that for you
later but he was basically saying like effective
field Theory you know is is extremely is extremely
uh productive and and it's it's led to multiple
discoveries high energy physics and and so forth
but um but it made me think you know of this of
this fact that we we hear things from people
like Nema uh up the road from you at Princeton
and others that you know space time is doomed and
and uh there's really nothing you know I think I
think yeah I can't really repeat what he said but
uh because it's a PG no he he hopefully will come
on the podcast but but you know essentially
that you know it's it's it's it's it's only
we're only seeing kind of a a shadow of of some
low energy limit of some higher energy effective
field so admission made me think what is so crazy
about thinking about Newtonian Dynamics I mean
why is that so sacrosanct um the symmetries in
it we knew since the time of of Isaac Newton
we both have great affinity for um but that
we knew since you know that there were there
were flaws in it and inherently contradictions
that needed to be revealed and and corrected by
a true but still effective Theory like gr and
so why hold sucker saying you know these these
prints or the Newtonian physics you know all the
more so uh you know if we aren't really sure that
we have a final true theory only an effective
Theory what do you say to you know kind of those
I have I agree with Dan that effective
theories have been very very successful
but the reason they've been successful is
the the idea of effective field theories
is to identify the symmetries of the system
and then construct a class of mathematical
models a general class of mathematical models
that are consistent with those symmetries
and but Amanda does not do that it doesn't it's
not in some sense it's not mathematically
self-consistent you know I don't want to
I probably can't get through all the details both
mind if you sort of start with over here and then
you go over here and then you go over here and
then you go over here and then you go right here
game of telephone you know yeah you know tomorrow
is this is Super Bowl Sunday and then by the time
it comes back it's like you know you know Franklin
Delaware Roosevelt is about to be Resurrected
it doesn't hang together yeah there are issues
with you know kind of I think superpositions
and linearity and so forth but let's take the
opposite attack now let me get your impressions
about a highly symmetric Theory and and uh some
would say a super symmetric theory in other words
you know particle physics we you know we've been
kind of living under this notion that there's some
unification that's possible um and that you know
there's a theory of everything that lurking uh
perhaps um for models that that basically ape
or replicate you know very simple symmetries
from things like relativist decline Gordon
equations and and make those you know operate
on manifolds with vibrating string I mean that's
very symmetric right and and are those past guests
you know Sabina hasenfelder Neil Turok and others
who argue that we've been LED astray by Beauty and
the Symmetry and that it's no longer you know in
last 50 years pursuing that was very fruitful for
the preceding 30 years but you know until the time
of your you know fellow Professor gel on Caltech
you know I don't I don't see that it's been as
productive as to Warrant you know the attention
to it versus the attention the you know you know
pitiful amount of attention to something like mon
which I agree is doesn't have those symmetry
so how do you reconcile those two sides you
know where you're advocative of pursuing things
that have inherent properties Beauty symmetry
Etc and yet in string theory and supersymmetry
they haven't borne any fruit at least not yet
I think the issue is that um you know
ultimately what we do as physicists
um a scientist his construct mathematical models
to explain results of experiments and observation
and the simpler the mathematical model the better
um and but you want that mathematical model to be
mathematically self-consistent and you also
want to satisfy certain basic requirements
and the basic requirements you know are
consistent with the the symmetries that are
either assumed or observed experimentally um and
throughout the 20th century we were lucky because
um you know for various historical societal
reasons and just you know technological advances
and capabilities we were able to very rapidly
uncover you know a variety of layers you know
first going down to the atom and then into the
constituency atom the nucleus the electron protons
and neutrons the quarks left you know Etc um and
we were we had a lot of experimental data that
guided us and told us what the symmetries were you
look at the data and they're the patterns we had
tons of information you know when boar came across
you know came up with the you know his model for
the the hydrogen atom um chemists and physicists
have been measuring spectral lines from various
types of gases for 50 years like huge huge tables
of all these numbers and all of a sudden you know
with the Bohr's model he started you start to have
some insight on where those numbers came from you
know bomber I think it was the 1860s or something
like that when he came up with this formula that
was the one paper that he wrote but still it
took him 50 years from that to you know a model
but then after that things you know what's wrong
I mean the Bohr Adam is not the true description
of the atom but it's remarkably effective at
a plane it was a phenomenal it was a a simple
mathematical model to account for the the you know
some of the observations and then it led the way
um you know with more data more insights more
measurements to you know more fundamental what
we believe now is a more fundamental description
but we got lucky in the 20th century we had
Nuclear Physics we had protons and neutrons we
had beta Decay we had all these different nuclear
impatient decaying and then hadron spectroscopy
you had neutrons and protons and Pines and chaos
and romezons it was just like all over the place
and then you know we had accelerators and we had
the w we had the Z we had Precision tests of
um you know qcd um you know we had uh what's
it called Reggie trajectories is that what's
called um we had um we had um you know the
part-time model deep in elastics pattern
so it's just a huge amount of information
um and so our mathematical models were guided
you know we like to think that we're you know
everything was because of you know some type of
like genius Insight um The Genius insights were
pretty Elementary it's got to be mathematically
self-consistent It's gotta account for the
observation experiments we had so much data and
you know guiding us but you know now we've kind of
you know I don't know if we haven't hit a wall but
we're getting slower the you know the the sizes
and price tags for accelerators are going to take
us to the next level keeps getting you know bigger
the time scales price tags are bigger time scales
are longer and so we just don't have the same kind
of guidance from an experiment that we did you
know 50 hundred years ago I don't think that you
know that should lead us to abandon the notion
of symmetry it's just that we just don't know
what the what those symmetries are and so it's
you know been happening over the past 30 40 50
years is largely guesswork we try guessing some
symmetries maybe there's a left right symmetric
model maybe they're super symmetric models
maybe there's you know generalized symmetries
But ultimately we're limited
because we don't have data
so now of course the the ultimate of all
symmetries at least in cosmology is the
cosmological principle and and lately you know
the first kind of Crisis we're going to talk about
um is the notion of claim at pretty high
significance by by many other by many
people but in particular subie or SAR Khan
group that Oxford I think where he's at but
other ones that that claim that the cosmological
principle should be not overthrown but needs to
be evaluated in the context of the distribution
of radio galaxies versus the CMB dipole versus
um other tracers ksz things like that what what do
you make of I mean first of all what what you know
would you just quit and and go back to you know
slinging pizzas and uptown Manhattan or what would
you do if the cosmological principle it needs uh
needs to be jettisoned I mean we just go into like
apoplexy or or what and then second of all what
sort of mental energy do you expend on such claims
um I actually think it's these kinds of
tests are very important and very interesting
um I think if we found a violation of the
cosmological principle I wouldn't think
of that as the end of the world or the
end of the universe um in some sense um
we might even expect it at some level um one thing
I tell my students is that in in physics there's
no such thing as an integer there's no such thing
as an irrational number there's no such thing as
zero there's no such thing as Infinity you know
ultimately all of our models are approximations to
the reality to reality and again the cosmological
principle um is great as a you know when it comes
to assembling our model of what it knows
essential tool in guiding the development
of our current cosmological model but um you know
our notion of inflation is that the universe is
not perfectly homogeneous there are variations
from one point to another and we know that we've
got galaxies we've got primordial perturbation
Cosmic microwave background and there's no reason
to expect that on super Horizon distances
which we can't access observationally that
there might be departures from you know perfect
homogeneity nisotropy and so if we did find the
cosmological principles violated if we did find
those a preferred orientation in the universe
um I think that'll be great it'll be great
you know because we where there's a limit to
what we can infer from whatever observations we
have and there might be subtle departures from
the things we've always assumed that are going
to lead us in that direction of these kinds of
tests I always think I think we should always be
testing you know all of the assumptions that we've
made we shouldn't hold anything you know sacred
or holy let's say you know God hands you you know
a letter and it says a cosmological principle is
not valid you know on this scale at you know at
five Sigma seven Sigma whatever um correct me if
I'm wrong I mean that really wouldn't affect I
mean we wouldn't like change the you know the
B mode power Spectra you know for example it
wouldn't it wouldn't undo in the relevant you know
cosmological epochs surface of last scattering
even Bao even Epoch of of you know Lambda
domination would it really haven't like would
you have to change you know uh cam or CMB fast as
we used to use it um whether it be any practical
implication on a daily basis other than like
cosmologists don't know what they're talking about
uh you know what would it how would it affect your
life or my life as working cosmologists if at all
um I think if there was if we did find there was
a preferred orientation preferred Direction in
the universe um ultimately it would affect um you
know the calculation of cosmological observables
um we do know that any departure of strong
homogeneity or isotropy are very very small
and so it wouldn't be like a huge you would
have to throw cam away completely but there
might I mean hopefully if we're doing things
you know for making progress sooner or later
there would be some type of tweak of
cam or plastic we'd have to implement um
yeah yeah but I mean suppose somebody
came in and they said you know
the Earth you know Columbus Christopher
Columbus comes in your office one day
okay in the 1400s he says the
Earth is round you're like
and then he like sails around he says okay watch
I'm going that way he leaves and then you know six
later years later he comes back from that side
yes it is wrong you demonstrate I believe it
it's round and then you go down the hallway to you
know your theoretical physics group you say look
Christopher Columbus has found that the Earth is
round he went that way and he came back this way
and then for the next 50 years people decide
the Earth is round and that is we have the
Earth is round principle which is a fundamental
principle of you know of Earth studies and then
somebody winds up taking a trip to the Himalayas
and they see that the Himalayas are really big and
they come back and say the Earth isn't round the
Earth is not round it's got bumps in it yes yes
but it's still round it's not perfectly round but
it's pretty damn close that's right and it's like
those bumps are interesting they're interesting
they tell us a lot about the history of the earth
and its Evolution and its structure but it does
not eliminate the Earth is rounds principle I
think that's where we are with the cosmology we
have this cosmological principle the universe
should be homogeneous and isotropic but we know
that it's not perfectly homogeneous it's not
perfectly isotropic we've supplanted that now
with the notion of statistical homogeneity and
statistical isotropy and those um are very very
good descriptions of the universe but there's no
reason expecting them to be perfect and if we
find violations that'll be great because any
such violation is not going to overturn the entire
structure of cosmological theory but it'll tell us
it'll give us a you know a lot more
clues about where the universe came from
yeah as a another shout out to a famous Isaac
and we already talked about Isaac Newton Isaac
Asimov said you know if you believe the Earth
is flat you're wrong and if you believe the
Earth is a sphere you're also wrong but you're
less wrong and uh that's a guiding principle I
think for what yeah good science uh should be and
I want to Pivot from from that to the you know to
maybe moving forward in time from you know the Big
Bang itself uh which will get back to maybe talk
about inflation later on but um but there was a
kind of a social contagion that went on over the
summer uh where uh there's a lot of attention
paid to an article written by uh a person who
went to Colombia he might have even been there
when you were there uh named Eric Lerner who's
a plasma uh physicist he's interested in Fusion
all sorts of fun things not a PhD not a professor
but he has this you know book from the 90s called
The Big Bang never had and and this article went
around based on the web telescope data of early
spiral galaxy observations that the you know he
claims there's not enough time since the Big
Bang to generate uh this spiral phenomena and
that it's in conflict with other things and so
he believes in a steady state a static universe
uh which has Myriad problems and and I debated him
not I kind of had an asynchronous debate with him
uh and uh had Garen Lewis on and he and I spoke
about about this this gentleman's work but anyway
uh what do you make of this if let's say we were
to really and as I think it is true that we don't
understand why these galaxies observed by Hubble
first in the 90s when he wrote the book the first
time or web galaxies which are higher redshift
and redder and easier to see with web than HST
but still some of them were seen by uh Hubble um
why why is it that you know people you know what
would that call into question or if anything
does it does it cause us to reevaluate Lambda
CDM uh does it cause us to reevaluate only and
I say only in quotes you know Galaxy structure
formation what what do you mean did you hear about
these claims what do you make of them if if you're
hearing about them for the first time I didn't
hear about these claims but claims like this
come around all the time yeah I mean I
remember when I was in graduate school
postdoc people were starting to discover
galaxies of redshift close to one
ruled out the cosmological model because how can
you make a Galaxy All the Way by Rich matters or
this cluster of galaxies and redshift of one
and then like Quasar start appearing you know
at higher Rich if how can you make the quasars
there's just not enough time for it there's
also this issue people there were ages for stars
people had um Stellar ages or elaborate stars and
collaborate clusters that were older you know than
the age of the universe how's that happen that's
kind of rules rules out there but I remember you
probably didn't know David Schram David Schram
was a larger than life figure yeah yeah and uh I
remember it was one of these debates going on at
the time and you know it came into class and he
said you know the Earth is round we'd understand
how tornadoes form it's very complicated but we
do not have a successful theory of tornadoes that
consistent with around Earth but that does not
mean that the Earth isn't round it means we'd
understand how tornadoes form it's the same thing
going on here um galaxies especially these five
reduction galaxies are very complicated is a lot
more complicated but they're not as well observed
measured uh you know as local galaxies but
they're very complicated objects um that's
just a University of Illinois UIUC last week I was
talking to the storage Shapiro and I was asking
him um if what if he knows how supermassive
black holes perform so BC Quasar is a very
high red shift with very large masses you know
quasers get a 10 billion solar masses an adult
and it's not clear how you get so much mass
in such a small volume how you produce such a
massive black hole a such a short period of time
but the ideas about this how this might happen
and it doesn't violate any fundamental
physical you know theorem uh I don't know
how these supermassive black holes are formed
to me that's the most interesting puzzle but it
doesn't I've never worried that it invalidates
the our cosmological models no more so than
our inability to predict weather patterns
invalidates are the Earth is round principle
so um I wanted uh to now pivot into more maybe
I always say red meat but I'm going to say
um you know vegan white tofu uh for My Vegan
listeners um and that's something near and dear
to to both of our hearts and that's the the
so-called Hubble tension which is one of the
more prominent tensions at least in observational
cosmology and I had on Adam Reese your colleague
there I had on John Mather also calling there uh
and you know we discussed some of these some of
these issues uh but I'm tired of the blandishments
Marco I'm trying to well we need more data I want
somebody to come out tell me what the heck's
going on and and not postpone or say you know
if we don't understand it that would be really
exciting it's like remember when like in the 90s
when they said we're going to build LHC and or
the late you know late 90s relationship we're
going to build the LHC and if we don't find the
Higgs that'll be really exciting like if you
don't find the Higgs you're all going to be out
of a job you know so let's let's talk you know
brass tax here what's going on and who's right
what this I I know you're a man of very strong
opinions and you won't weasel or waffle out of
this who's right Mark tell tell me I need to know
really honestly I have no idea what's going on
if you had a bet if you had a bet your your new
dog your Rottweiler I don't know um first of all
can you outline from your perspective you know
why this is important first outline that you know
upper level undergraduate sort of level uh for my
brilliant audience but what is a Hubble tension
is it a problem um you know we have Exquisite
measurements from two different camps they don't
agree but what are the implications for cosmology
I don't know I mean I get asked this all the time
you know what's going on talk straight to me I can
handle it DOC I don't know I mean if I actually
knew that there was something wrong with the CMV
analysis they were just you know they forgot to
like you know you know there's C code they just
forgot to like put the right compiler flag on
it or something or if they just missed a factor
of two somewhere if I knew that I would have I
would have published it I would have told the
world and we wouldn't be worrying about it same
thing with the Supernova date if I like went in
there and realized oh you're just pointing the
telescope at the wrong exception variable you
know that's the one you're supposed to be looking
at then we wouldn't be worrying about it I mean I
really don't no um I mean CMB analyzes I know and
understand um and there's nothing wrong with them
a lot of people have looked at them we've
got data from several different telescopes
um that data's been analyzed and re-analyzed
by a variety of different people and groups and
you know the Hubble parameter that we infer from
all those measurements is low 67 and 68. and then
they're the Supernova measure and um I'm kind of
in a probably have a different opinion or view of
this than most other people um because when I go
to work I walk past Adam's office in the morning
and I see him and he's always in front of
his screen actually calculated and damn it
okay he's not like uh just smoking
cigars and like having the people
he's actually like
and you know every couple of days or every couple
weeks on archive there's some paper that appears
or someone says well they forgot to take into
account the metallicity evolution or they
forgot to take a look out and then they go past
Adam's office I'm like hey did you see this paper
on archive about the metal issue it'll say well
actually yeah you know what they said is correct
you're taking the continentalistic evolution but
look he did it and then he'll show me you know
I'll go to the screen third results he said okay
this is the analysis you know without it and this
is the analysis with it and they're right it does
move things down but it's half a sigma and it's
already in the analysis we already take that into
account and so you know all these like you know
things that people you know you know lob at the
measurements he he bats them all the way and so
and he also does the now like he does the
CMB analysis it's you know I couldn't do the
Supernova now he's a very impressive scientist
yeah and it's not just that the other thing
um so I told you I wrote this in rev article
on public attention to the dark energy without
him and I'm familiar with the observations that
people have done but in the process of writing the
article and actually like you know Adam wrote most
of the observational Parts but you know I want
to read through and make sure everything hangs
together and uh you know and understand and also
um at the same time um I'm across the street from
the Space Telescope Science Institute and so I
see Space Telescope you know scientists there and
one of the things I've come to appreciate is that
um you know there's a huge amount of
um calibration and um benchmarking and
bootstrap tests and Engineering infrastructure
behind HST and it's the same telescope that's
been making all the measurements that they
use for these for these Hubble parameter
measurements you know over the past 30 years
and um and so it's not like they're you know
using one telescope to observe this system another
telescope to observe that system and then try to
figure out how to calibrate this one against
that there's a lot of you know it's it's all
calibrated against itself internally calibrated
and so it's not that you know someone's just being
sloppy or forgetting to do something this is
as careful of measurement I think you know
as any that you would find anything yeah and
so it's not something that's just easily waved
away and so when people ask me you know what's
going on you know who's wrong I just I don't know
I spoke here remotely at least two months
ago at UCSD in Berkeley we have this kind
of joint oh yeah energy astral product and you
spoke about possible solutions to it and and I
um I brought up my favorite personal favorite and
I I beg your Indulgence just to hear the reason
why of course you're very familiar with primordial
magnetic fields but uh that's my preferred
explanation for it uh you know based on work
by Levon pagosian and another colleague of his
um uh whose name I'm forgetting right now but I
did a video about how their paper basically you
know could lead to a possible solution of the
reconciliation of the tension without costly
Psychotherapy and the argument you know could
be better recapitulated by you but nevertheless
uh the reason I like it are philosophically
attracted to it is that we know magnetic fields
exist and we don't know exactly how magnetic
fields the size of a micro guy house come to
be in the Milky Way galaxy or you know Nana you
know Nano Gauss and the inter-cluster medium
but we've never detected correct me if I'm wrong a
truly primordial magnetic field uh and yet we see
the the the you know kind of the the Sprouts that
must have emerge from some primordial seed so what
do you make of the solution via the primordial
field since there's you know an infinite number
of possible you know resolutions theoretical
explanations for the Hubble tension what do you
make of that argument that the primordial magnetic
field energy plays a role and then what do you
make of your own uh model or uh suggestion uh that
it might be due to evolution of some primordial
field or so forth but you'll be better equipped to
deal with explanations as well so first what are
your you know kind of straw man and Steel Man the
primordial magnetic field and then the models that
you've worked on um I like the primordial magnetic
field idea because as you say it's economical
um we don't have to completely reinvent
fundamental physics come up with these
scalar Fields with wacky potentials that
we had no idea why they would be there
um the um only it's not an issue I think um
the limitation with the magnetic fields so
the only reason I don't just jump up and say I
think it's going to be a magnetic field is that
um it's very difficult to calculate fully the
implications of these primordial magnetic fields
um it's fundamentally non-linear you know
the standard cosmological model when we
describe customer pick background
and massage because we got lucky
um it's a simple system the fluctuation amplitudes
are small and so we know how to calculate
um you know our priori it didn't have to be
that way if the primordial density perturbation
amplitude was more like 10 to the minus two
instead of 10 to the minus five which is as
likely from a theoretical point of view is 10 to
the minus five um then we would have had a much
harder time actually you know interpreting the
data and primordial magnetic fields it's the the
theory is fundamentally non-linear and so it's
just difficult to calculate um but you know see
yeah I think it probably warrants more attention
and more effort um that's just not something that
I have yet done I think it is interesting and
important and so much to do it maybe I should
do it but I just haven't yet okay and I'll talk
about the model you discussed um our seminar yeah
I mean early Dark Energy you know the the
minus is that we introduced this with into
this scalar field with features and
parameters that come out of nowhere
um the advantage that we know how to
calculate the same type of perturbation Theory
and so we can you know write down the mathematical
model and then evolve it calculate and you know
figure out the the observational implications
and it works I don't know why it works I don't
I can't say look there's a it's just what the
doctor ordered and you know this is you know
there's this is exactly what we would have
expected it's kind of a back to maybe model
um and from the point of view of you know what you
know your particle theory friends would call a UV
completion um I mean we don't know where this
comes from but it does work um and I have to
say when we wrote that paper in 2018 I did not
expect it to work I thought we would write you
know an upper limits paper you know we tried
to do this and in this paper we showed that
this ridiculous idea in fact as you might have
expected doesn't work to move on with your lives
um but you know it turns out that it did work
it was surprising and I found that you know
interesting that it could work because none
of the other Solutions work all the late time
solutions they don't work so to me this was a
model a ridiculous model but at least it works
once you're willing to take this bitter pill
everything else follows um and other people
get interested in WoW as well and um I think until
we have anything better right so you know somebody
comes in and you know you know shows that the
you know lines 683 in the C code that they've
been using to analyze the the ACT data you know
I was missing a comma that changes everything um
but I don't proselytize I don't think it's the
truth so I don't have to be more interesting
and then we got lucky I don't really understand
it then you know act came out with an analysis
two years later and you know the lead author is
Colin Hill and Colin is like really knows what
he's doing with data and it's unbiased you
know he had written several earlier papers
analyzing large-scale structure showing
that it was disfavored early dark energy
and then he was the first author on this act
collaboration paper where they looked at the
data fully objectively without any intended
consequence without any biases and they found
that the ACT data was um more consistent with
early Dark Energy within Lambda CDN which I don't
I mean a lot of uncertainties and issues you know
that in some ways it's something that's a very
preliminary analysis I don't think it's at all the
last word it was done on the fraction of the ACT
data it was done fairly early on and as you know
whenever you do a CMD experiment you don't just
get straight to the science results you discover
the science simultaneously with the instrument
very valued collaborator on Simon's Observatory
and and of course he'll be uh having a lot more
to say when our instrument gets first light next
year uh over there in the Atacama Desert pivoting
back to where we began with broken symmetries
uh I mentioned you know if not for the broken
symmetry between matter and antimatter yeah you
and I wouldn't be having this conversation and
yet it's a very tiny asymmetry but it's you know
hard to think of something more impactful and I
was reading a paper which you know I I remember
when it came out because I remember the events by
the alpha magnetic spectrometer on the space
station back uh five six years ago and then
remember the paper that came out that Vivian uh
pulan wrote with with you and and several others
including Joe silk uh and that was entitled uh
you know where do these uh anti-thelium events
come from so uh we won't talk so much about the
uh results although I'm not sure that they did
stand up to you know further reanalysis
or were they confirmed uh can you first
say something about that and then can you talk
about these anti-helium and anti-matter clouds
uh that are existent in this model uh and how
they could provide the source of some of these
uh of these particles that seem to be observed
at least by the AMS on the ISS so first of all
are these measurements still you know uh are
they still credible or or do we have further
you know disconfirmation about that you didn't
warn me that you're going to ask me about this
yeah yeah I remember I know the paper I remember
the paper I haven't kept up though with it that's
the thing um so when we wrote that paper the
the anti-healing results were not yet refereed
um or sort of talks and it was understood that
it was preliminary um but even though it's
preliminary there are certain interesting things
about it that um were unusual and caught our eye
so I don't really know what the status
of that is I have not heard a lot more
um the anti-clouds were kind of a crazy idea
um and I don't think that you know when I
looked at that paper in that model I didn't
necessarily put it forward as a model of what
I think is actually going on but um sort of as
a model of how crazy things would have to get
if this result holds up ah right so I mean
how how much do we because this I want to
Pivot to the extremely early universe
saccharov conditions and whatnot so
um how do you you know kind of get your
attention drawn to an anomaly or a crisis
um you know in in cosmology versus particle
physics and you know how much progress could we
make um the you know baryon antivirion asymmetry
problem from Pure cosmological you know insights
observations data uh pure Theory you know how
much of a concern is it that you know I mean
the critic will say well you have this edifice
built on Sand you've got all this you know uh
or anti-sand you've got all these dark Forces
and Fields you you know 95 of the universe is
completely alien to us if they exist at all
some people say like Milgram it doesn't exist
um and even people say that dark energy doesn't
exist I think sarkar had some papers about this
uh these you know prominent people so uh what do
you say to people that like how can you predict
you know that we'll see fluctuations in the CMB
from inflationary you know gravitational waves
if you don't even know why there's matter versus
antimatter in the universe uh to what extent do
that type of tension keep you up at night
I think there are two things that I think
that interests me so one of them is that in
cosmology and particle physics there are tons
of anomaly just tons at any given day there's
like tons of measurements that disagree with
what we would have expected based on the standard
model or our modeling of astrophysical systems
and then there are tons of theorists thinking
about things but for some reason um the vast
majority of theorists tend to gravitate or
cluster around a very narrow range of anomalies
and um I think to a large extent cosmologists
are bosons and if somebody's thinking about the
Hubble tension they will also think about the
Hubble tension they're not going to think okay
there's 16 people thinking about the humble
tension that's good that's a very important
tension we don't understand it so much to be
thinking about it but then over here there's
this other tension and maybe we should
have you know eight or nine or ten people
thinking about that and then you know there
should be you know if this was a business
you know we would have a manager at the top
and says okay there's this tension there's
this tension there's this tension okay you
choose five people to be on your team you
think about this tension saldaryaga we got this
tension over here take five of your friends go
think about that kazowski we need you guys in
Pittsburgh to be looking about this tension but
it doesn't work that way everybody decides
what they're gonna do and everybody winds
up focusing in a very narrow range of um
problems um that is the question you know
what when do I choose no how do I choose what
to work on I don't really know but I think um
I think you know some approximation I have some
students and post docs and I have collaborators
elsewhere and we stood around and we brainstorm
we talk about things and we read papers and uh
occasionally you know I mean often will you know
talk about some anomaly that appear in the data
we'll try to understand it and try to figure out
you know is there any simple obvious explanation
you know in the analysis or in the interpretation
and you know most of the time we'll conclude yeah
it's another we understand what's going on and
that's it we don't have anything else to say
but sometimes um we'll see something like
that and we actually have something to say
um so one example is just a there's a
paper that showed up almost a year ago
an archive by Mark Postman and Todd Lauer and
the New Horizons team hmm right and um it was a
very you know the style of the paper was very
astronomical it looked like you know an app
J abstract the language was very um astronomical
and so I I think it just passed a lot of people by
but I know Mark Postman because he's a Space
Telescope Science Institute and I see him all
the time and so I've read you know through it
and as it turns out they did this incredible
measurement so you know about New Horizons yeah
that Pluto yeah so I took a pictures of Pluto
and Karen and it was like incredible absolutely
amazing that something that humans built got that
close to Pluto and took such detailed pictures of
Pluto and Caron less than a lifetime after Pluto
was discovered yeah and less than the human life
two years after launch right yeah yeah um and then
but it didn't have any breaks in it right they
just sent it out there then you got sail past
Pluto take a bunch of pictures yeah but we can't
but then it kept sailing on and then a couple
years later took a picture that asked that Kuiper
Belt object peanut shaped thing but it's still out
there and it's moving you know it's going for
it's like 70 a.u from the Sun so it turns out
that um nobody has ever been able to measure the
cosmic Optical background so you look at the sky
and it's dark nobody's actually ever been able to
measure how bright the sky actually is in Optical
we know in radio frequency that's the cosmic
microwave background nobody's ever been able to
measure the cosmic Optical background because
there's so much scattered light from the sun
so even HST and jwst they're they're above the
Earth's atmosphere but they're still you know they
can't do this measurement because they're still
in the solar system all right and there's a lot
of scattered life from the Sun so this you know
New Horizons the camera was not that sophisticated
it wasn't the greatest thing that camera that
anybody's ever built it's not a jwst camera but
it was out there 70 a year from the Sun where the
scatter light from the sun is reduced by fours of
magnitude and so mark Postman toddler went to the
New Horizons people like just point it at nowhere
you're doing nothing else with that it's gonna be
a while until they find another camera belt out of
it just point it at nothing and take a picture
and see what happens and so they did that and
they mentioned the cosmic Optical background they
got the first High signal to noise measurement the
cosmic Optical background and the interesting
thing was that Mark Postman and Todd Lauer
um you know Mark Postman was involved in the
original Hubble Deep Field he knows more as
much about Galaxy populations um at high red
shift at low red shift as anybody yeah and so
they had an expectation of what the cosmic Optical
background would be due to the integrated light
from all the unresolved galaxies that we know
to be out there and it turns out that the cosmic
Optical background they measured was twice what
they expected from all the galaxies non-galaxy
populations in the universe the very first time
that comes from some star that we know about
somewhere there's another Photon coming from God
knows where so the reason so we wound up writing
a paper and the reason we wrote a paper is that
an obvious you know exotic physics explanation is
um decay of an Axion particle two photons and
um my group had been working on this um new
type of cosmological measurement called Blind
intensity mapping and um JPL your your friends
um you know Jamie Bach yeah yeah Jamie's got
this project called spirox it's going to be
launching you know for the next year or two
and it's going to do live intensity mapping
and we realize that if that Cosmic Optical
background access is in fact due to decay
of an exotic particle it's going to show up in
spirits um you know the many thousands of signal
the spirits is just it's like gonna be like a
taking candy from a baby for Spirit to you know
verify or disprove this hypothesis so that's the
only idea we had the idea that it might be to the
two photons to give an accident that is not at
all profound that would be an embarrassing paper
to write but we wrote the paper because we were
able to we knew that this idea would be tested it
was a great Target for spirits yeah and as soon
as the humble tension goes I mean I've been I I
heard about it a lot because you know Adam's
at um and Chuck is right down there next yeah
but here you know think about hearing about a lot
and um in 2016 I wrote this paper Tommy Carl who's
a graduate student the basic idea behind early
Dark Energy again it's not that profound or it's
pretty simple and obvious so we did write a simple
paper about that in 2016 but it took two more
years to actually do the complete analysis um the
to figure out whether this idea could be made or
would that then happen you know we we
as you know look for a Time dependent
um but not but spatially isotropic Cosmic
birefringence polarization rotation of
emotes or grad modes into curl modes as I will
always call them and uh we look for a time to so
far we haven't seen that bicep hasn't seen them
uh and and so forth would this signal I mean is
there any con kind of neutral constraint or
concomitant you know um limit that could be
put on let's say you accept these at face value
from uh from New Horizons would that give any
kind of hope for you to write a paper called the
the Axion pursuers guide or something like that
I don't think we need to write that paper
because um axions have just become the the
preferred um you know Workforce for theorists
thinking about exotic new physics and dark
matter and dark energy and really dark energy
um I don't think I'll be the person to write that
I've written some papers that have actions in them
but I'm a bit player in the hole all right all
right well I had on uh you know not too long ago
um it was David David Chalmers who's I think
well he's in New York I think he's at NYU
actually not Columbia but but anyway or maybe
he's like but the point is he's Australian he's
originally from Australia I said you know
you're well known uh for all these you know
the hard problem of Consciousness you know and
you know when I have AC DC also from Australia
on the into the impossible podcast I can't not
ask them to play You Shook Me All Night Long
it's just it's just it's not fair to them to
their Uber um someone ask you you know is that
really the the Pioneer and a lot of these ways
of thinking and the detectability of inflation
um or its constraint you know what is the
status of inflation from Markham mankowski's
perspective 30 years you know after we met or
uh you know we you really were were initiating
a whole field which would become my you know
my source of of where my bread gets buttered
what what do you view as the status
of inflation is it is it stronger than
ever but what's that what what kind of grade
would you give to inflation at this point and
um what what kind of perspectives do you have for
prospects for what we're going to do in the future
um I have to say that I mean
the basic status of inflation
um the basic idea I think is the
same as it was 30 40 years ago
um there have been a lot of um theoretical
developments that are interesting
um a lot of them done by people like Dan
Green um but also Leonardo sanatoreaga
um Daniel Bowman there's been this whole
um Jared Kaplan at Thea Fitzpatrick
um there was a you know starting about 15
years ago there were still papers on effective
field Theory descriptions of inflation
which I think are important because they
put inflation model building on that
level of mathematical self-consistency
um symmetries built in that I think isn't you know
one of the things we're supposed to be doing in
theoretical physics in terms of observation
experiment I have to say that inflation
is doing far better I think
than I ever would have expected
30 years ago so it's almost 30 years ago that I
started writing papers on CMD tests of inflation
and you know I was a postdoc and an assistant
professor and I was just trying to write papers
that made me seem clever so that I'd get a
job in the container and um and I remember
once you know we were I was giving a talk about
cosmological parameter determination with the CMB
this was you know 1995. and it was before wmf
was selected but they were proposing it was a
map at that time and I remember talking to David
Wilkinson who was the W from it and he said you
shouldn't be soaked and I was you know we wrote
these papers we're thinking in the best case
in the best case if they get all the money in
the world they have genius instrument Builders
and the thing doesn't blow up on the launch pad
and it makes it you know they get the funding
and they make a little bit in the best Pace they
should be able to make this measurement I remember
David Wilkins who came up to me after we're sick
it's really not that difficult he's like you know
it's not uh we can do this and I was like really
because you know Kobe we were coming off of Kobe
and you know Kobe took more than 20 years from
conception to launch it's all steady scenario yeah
we have an experiment like the the one the what we
had in mind is actually less than what map turned
out to be after a few years of observation and I
had in my mind this would take another 20 years
you know before this happened but as it turned
out you know the first results the first you
know results on um the the you know the first
acoustic peaks in the CNB power Spectrum came from
Boomerang in Spring of 2000 and then a year later
there was you know further measurements from Daisy
um that lined up right on top of each other and
it just it was astoundingly good we had no idea
if there would be realization you know there was
a really good chance it would all be completely
washed up by realization and we always thought
you know maybe for some reason the university
but probably you know it's important to
measurement to make just in case anything
um you know but it turned
out to be the experiments
turned out to be much better than
I thought and the agreement of the
the theory with the model is again much better
than I ever expected you know we see a power law
over three decades you see a spectral index which
is close to but not exactly equal to one you know
if it was exactly equal to one suppose you know
it was 2023 we had a plank we had W map we had
accurate spt and all the data said that N Sub
s is equal to 1.00 plus or minus 0.01 I don't
know if we would still be thinking about fish we
just say well you know that's a scale of various
factors that's what you expect but deflation is
a physical model and it predicts that it's not
exactly equal to one if predictions close to one
but not exactly the one so that you know when that
started emerging to me that was remarkable uh and
now we have measurements of the mass distribution
from lensing again we were writing papers about
this years ago but if you know when it actually
happened it was spectacular I think the status
of inflation is that the you know it was a great
idea 30 years ago one that should have been taken
seriously 30 years ago but I think it's a you know
it's harder to disregard it much much harder
to disregard it now than it was yeah 30 years
well Mark uh you've been so generous with your
time and and uh your attention uh all these many
years to little old me I can't resist to do what
I do with all my guests that honor me by coming
on the podcast and ask you just two existential
questions we have time for two of my patented
fantastic final four and the first one I'm going
to ask you about uh they're both related to
Sir Arthur C Clarke and the first one has to do
with his famous statement that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable from
Magic and the way I like to kind of put a spin
on it the Keating spin on it is to ask you What
discovery in all of science maybe just in your
local neck of the woods of science would you
most want to kind of trump it to the universe
and something that will endure as a byproduct of
the magic of of science and technology that human
beings or you have created and sort of uh give
us a little Swagger for all humankind [Music]
for science from science yeah I thought I'll
I'll give you a minute to think but Feynman
who is Sean Carroll's uh previous office
uh occupant at Caltech he said the most
astonishing thing in the in the shortest fewest
amount of words is the atomic hypothesis so that
everything's made of atoms so I wonder from
your perspective what is the most astonishing
thing about the that humans have discovered
about the universe about science anything
I don't know I think this cosmological model that
we have is pretty remarkable um I think that's a
Confluence of a number of things um you know ideas
in theory but also the technology that allows us
to make the measurements but it's also a product
of the fact that the Universe has cooperated
um you know as I said the the fluctuation
amplitude is small which means that we can
treat the perturbations with simple calculations
um and you know the universe is very very close
to isotropic and homogeneous and turns out it's
a very simple Universe you would have never
you know if someone 150 years ago told you
that look in the next 150 years people are going
to understand the largest scale structure of the
universe you wouldn't have expected that the thing
would have turned out to be so simple yeah that's
right so we got lucky you know with the the with
the cooperation you know through a collaboration
of Theory technological advancements you know
really bold and talented experimentalists like you
know you and people that you work with and have
worked with um and the cooperation of the universe
we assemble this incredible model so we can you
know say with some confidence what was going on
you know just a few seconds after the big bang
the standard model of elementary particle theory
pretty remarkable that's a to me I've been
teaching Quantum field theory for a couple
of years now and every year I've tried something
a little bit different so that I keep learning
and it's a it's a mathematical structure of
quantum field theory is absolutely remarkable
um so Mark with that I want to ask one final
question also kind of uh provoked by Sir Arthur C
Clarke he said a lot of fun things that are really
enjoyable to whip out at faculty meetings such as
for every expert there's an equal and opposite
expert uh but one of his quips I want to uh lay
on you right now is our final question and then
we'll wrap up uh and that is when a elderly but
distinguished scientist says something is possible
he or she is most likely right but when he or she
says something is impossible they're most likely
wrong now I'm not calling you elderly and you're
only a couple years older than me I think uh
but you're distinguished I don't ask you in
that context what have you changed your mind about
what have you been wrong about if anything [Music]
oh I've been wrong about Lots
it's kind of interesting though
I think you know having let's see I've
been I started as a professor 28 years ago
um and I had certain Notions about how things work
and how scientists work um that I now realize are
completely wrong I had Notions about how they
graduate students should be trained 30 years
ago that are in my Notions about how they
should be trained are completely different
um a quick example give me a quick example
how how have you changed what's something you
changed with regard to graduate education I think
I was a you know when I first started at Columbia
I was a probably a real hard ass about all the
classes that students need to take and all those
things technical things that they need to master
before they can really be successful in research
and they still think that all those
technical skills in Mastery are important
but I now my you know now I think that
the most important thing that graduate
students do is get involved in research
as soon as they get into graduate school
I mean if it happens with anybody who's ever had a
graduate student you have a graduate student that
come in the first date they don't know anything
they don't know why this guy is blue they don't
know why the grass is green they don't know you
know where to find their office they don't know
anything they can't they don't you know how to do
not attack anything um and you know within three
years like you're like sitting across the desk
for them for like you know talking about what
they're working on and you realize they're like
explaining things to you that you never thought
about and it doesn't happen because you're
like sitting there like giving them lectures
and saying do this problem do this problem do this
problem then come back and show me your Solutions
I don't do that but uh yeah the most important
it's like you know teaching people to swim
you know when I was a kid take swimming lessons we
stood at the they have a stand to the side of the
pool and perfect our Strokes you know they give us
free feedback yeah that's good that's good that's
how you do it and perfect the stroke and then I
get the water and it goes completely worthless
that's right and uh theory and practice are
very different well Mark I want to thank you
so much personally uh for being such a just a
mentor a friend I I always think you know when
I hear some crazy idea what would Mark think
and and it's not always the sober voice of
reason that you often provided me in my career
but it was the encouragement to do things like
come up with you know how we would actually do
bicep and and see it through the fruition and
now to see 22 years later you know bicep array
is still operating at the South Pole and we have
a hundred and you know 10 million dollar project
called the Simons Observatory which features three
you know basic uh direct descendants of bicep
type ideas which Trace themselves back to your
paper with uh your colleagues Andrew Jeffy good
friend and lemon Wang uh but that's just one of
many ways you've influenced me personally you
don't have to respond you don't have to rebut
this uh but I want to thank you on behalf of
my audience and and me in particular and I hope
we'll get to see each other soon out there in
balmy Baltimore or out here in sunny San Diego
well thanks to you from actually making bicep
happen for making polar bear happen for making
sandwich Observatory happen uh as I said
you know science and physics is mathematical
models for experiment results of experiments and
observations and so there's really no point to
anything that I would ever do without all the
things that you and your colleagues are doing
oh thank you Mark have a great day I'm
not just saying that I know I know you're
not you're not uh the sunshine in roses type uh
Mark thanks again yep it was great talk with you
foreign [Music]